[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
this video i'm going to be doing
something a little bit different than
usual
rather than deep diving into the rich
lore of harry potter i'm going to
instead be taking a look at the casting
decisions made for the harry potter
films now i thought the casting in harry
potter was great across pretty much all
of the films for pretty much all of the
roles there wasn't a single role where i
felt that the actor themself took away
from the character however there were of
course some instances in which the film
portrayal of the character didn't
exactly fit with the book i.e bonnie
wright with ginny and while i think that
the harry potter films did a fantastic
job overall i can't quite say the same
for the fantastic beasts films at least
the ones we've had so far they weren't
bad but definitely not as good as harry
potter even the characters that we hate
like umbridge were cast exceptionally
well imelda staunton was the perfect
umbrage but like with any film casting
is a huge part of the film creation
process and so it only makes sense that
many many other actors were nearly cast
in these roles in this video we're going
to be taking a closer look at some of
the actors that were ever so close to
being cast in some of these roles some
didn't get the role because they were
beat out by someone who was just a
better fit and others weren't able to
accept the role due to things like
scheduling conflicts without further ado
let's take a look at some of the actors
that could have been number one hugh
grant the first actor that we're going
to be looking at is british rom-com
heartthrob hugh grant grant is
predominantly known for his comedic
performances in romantic comedies but in
more recent years seems to have branched
out a little bit perhaps in fear of
being labeled a one-trick pony grant was
originally cast as you guessed it
wizarding heartthrob gilderoy lockhart
five-time winner of witch weekly's most
charming smile award the role of
lockhart required an actor that was able
to effectively convey the painfully
cheesy and simultaneously egotistical
nature of the character and grant us
cheese well lockhart was of course
harry's defense against the dark arts
professor in the chamber of secrets and
his character exudes an unusual mixture
of charming and despicable the role of
course eventually went to kenneth
branagh but this was actually only
because grant turned the role down grant
was in the middle of filming some other
things and it just didn't work out with
his schedule fortunately however branner
did an excellent job though i'm sure
grant would have done well in the role
as well number two ian mckellen gandalf
is that you yes that's right sir ian
mckellen famously known as the powerful
wizard gandalf in the lord of the rings
and magneto in x-men was actually
considered as a front-runner for
dumbledore as we know richard harris the
original dumbledore who was only in the
first two films passed away before the
film series could be completed this
meant that one of the largest roles in
the film franchise suddenly became
vacant and it only seems fitting that
warner brothers would want to cast
someone very experienced ian mckellen is
an incredibly versatile actor and given
that he is already an accomplished
on-screen wizard it made sense that he
would be considered for dumbledore
interestingly enough richard harris who
originally played dumbledore did not
think particularly highly of mckellen's
acting capabilities and once publicly
expressed that he thought that mckellen
was brilliant but passionless i'm not
sure if this had any bearing in casting
but the role was eventually given to
michael gambon who absolutely crushed it
gambon is an irish-born british actor
who trained under lawrence olivier
himself and has an extremely impressive
acting resume under his belt he
performed exceptionally well in the role
and i honestly think that he did a
better job than mckellen would have done
even though mckellen is a great actor
number three tim roth actor tim roth is
known for his roles in popular films
like pulp fiction reservoir dogs the hit
and many many more he's an english actor
with quite a diverse acting background
and with his years of experience i feel
as though he's the kind of actor that
could take on any sort of role however
the role that roth was originally
supposed to take on was none other than
potions professor severus snape the role
of severus snape was of course later
filled by actor alan rickman who
portrayed snape in a way that i don't
think any other actor could of all of
the casting in harry potter i think that
snape may have been the best when i saw
his character on screen i didn't think
oh that's alan rickman i just thought
that snape which if you consider the
fact that rickman was already quite
famous is quite an impressive feat he
completely submerged himself into the
role and i can't even begin to imagine
anyone else being snape though i'm sure
roth could have given it a go it
couldn't have worked out better that he
had to turn the role down roth was first
in line but dropped out so that he could
film tim burton's planet of the apes
number 4. tilde swinton matilda or tilda
swinton is a scottish actress known for
her roles in both independent art house
films and blockbusters over the course
of her career she's been cast in a very
diverse array of roles and i personally
felt that she was particularly good in
the role of the white witch in the
chronicles of narnia in whatever film i
see her in she always has a lot of
screen presence and with her scottish
background i'm sure she would have
slotted in perfectly with the harry
potter set swinton was originally
considered for the role of professor
trelawny the quirky unusual and perhaps
sometimes deluded divination professor
the role of trelloni was of course
eventually given to actress emma
thompson who did an exceptional job but
i honestly feel as though swinton would
have done a pretty good job here as well
swinton was offered the role before
thompson but had to turn it down due to
scheduling conflicts number 5 robin
williams the late robin williams was an
exceptional actor he had an extremely
impressive acting resume and over the
course of his career was always able to
effectively portray whatever was asked
of him his ability to convey emotion on
screen was a true testament to his
acting capabilities and charisma in
addition to being a popular stand-up
comic williams also had impressive
improvisational skills and is perhaps
best known for his roles in films like
dead poets society good will hunting and
mrs doubtfire williams was initially
considered for the role of hogwarts
gamekeeper rubius hagrid and was
actually the first choice of warner
brothers however the role was eventually
extended to actor robbie coltrane as
rowling wanted to preserve an
all-british cast coltrane did an
exceptional job at portraying the gentle
magical half giant and once again i feel
as though he was the perfect casting
decision however i can't help but wonder
what williams would have been like in
the role number 6. bob hoskins the late
bob hoskins was an english actor best
known for portraying tough guys
gangsters and working-class gentlemen
one of his most well-known roles was
eddie valiant in who framed roger rabbit
an iconic live-action animated comedy
released in 1988. hoskins was initially
considered for the role of potions
professor horace slughorn the eccentric
teacher that had a knack for collecting
his students hoskins lost out on the
role to english actor jim broadbent who
i know i keep saying this was perfect in
the role
though i feel that hoskins would have
given us quite a different
representation of slughorn i think he
would have still done well in the role
in spite of hoskins being turned down
for the role of slughorn it has been
reported that rowling wanted hoskins in
the film so badly that she even
considered writing a role for him in the
seventh book number 7. jk rowling jk
rowling have you heard the name before
though rowling is certainly not an
actress she was originally considered
for the role of harry's mother in the
philosopher's stone which could have
perhaps been a nice cameo i think that
of all of the roles lily possum would
have been the perfect role for her to
slot herself into had she wanted to
enter the film however rowling and the
casting directors eventually decided
that it would be best that they go with
someone else though it's not a
particularly large role actress
geraldine somerville who eventually went
on to assume the role did a good job
and that's it for this video did you
guys know about all of these potential
casting decisions do you think that any
of these actors would have been better
in the role than the actors that were
cast let me know down in the comment
section below until next time you're a
wizard harry
you